hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Prison architect now a
lot of people have wanted me to play
this game for a long time and I haven't
gotten around to it
mostly because I forgot about it but I'm
playing it now I've never played it
before and I don't imagine it's a lot
like The Escapist which is more a game
where you have to get out of a prison as
opposed to getting in hello CEO this is
a tough one there's a prisoner
incarcerated at this facility who's been
convicted of a double murder and
sentenced to death
Wow that's starting off on a cheerful
note that's where we come in we've been
contracted to construct an execution
chamber in time for the big guys big day
oh boy that's Hiro has too much of a
smile on his face for this subject
matter but oh wow okay I didn't expect
this to be as dark at this was this is
where I want the new facility to be
built
I want more executions I want to
maximize our execution Abul efficiency I
want to do all the stuff we can the
first step with any project like this is
to construct the building itself with
enough space inside to fit in execution
room and a holding cell so the guy in
the holding cell can see his doom before
it approaches and know what he's getting
himself into so let's get started
construct a new building here okay we
will also need an entrance to the new
execution facility yeah we can't have
people bashing through walls so eager to
get in there build a large jail door in
the south wall okay foundation brick
building wha-bam building object large
Dale door huh kabuki okay
got it I did it boss aren't you proud of
me boss your workmen are responsible for
the construction of buildings they'll
collect the steel and concrete from this
storeroom and take it to the
construction site well that's handy of
them hope they don't do anything wrong
or else they'll find themselves in jail
they'll use those raw materials to build
the foundations and framework of your
new building this is the slowest part of
the construction so you should plan
ahead when building new facilities while
we wait take a look around use the WASD
and arrow keys to move around and use
the mouse wheel to zoom in and out
okay oh I have a lovely prison if you
can say that about a prison I definitely
have one I wonder which one of these
[ __ ] is currently planning his
escape well they see
well I spy I spy a problem already all
of the jail cell doors seem to be open
hmm oh wow that's actually a pretty
efficient cooking staff that's the thing
about prisons they get three square
meals a day I'm not saying that like
that's a benefit but I'm saying they
efficiently do that sort of anywhere I'm
not gonna make any political statements
or anything but I'm just
prisons are bad especially here in
America but prisons are bad hello inside
the building I want to sell in an
execution room you got it boss anything
for you partition the space by
constructing some brick walls okay brick
walls ahh
boink and a boink I did it and boink and
a boink
and I'm guessing you want some probably
some doors in between those but I don't
know exactly what you want in between
the doors oh man you guys are slow but
things seem to be going well oh yeah
this is a for-profit prison which exists
in real life which is a very bizarre
thing but it does exist so we got a
making taken of the correct prison
population to be able to do what we need
to do hi Stacy what are you doing in
there what's oh I thought I thought that
was gonna say something else way mark
for airborne okay
all right done we did it now at large
jail doors to those dividing walls you
can rotate an object before placement by
clicking the middle mouse button or
press R yeah I could have done that
before I actually got in there [ __ ]
no stop that okay boink got it Babbitt
boop boop boop
good good thing they just got those in
storage all right we did it
cool that's looking good now we need to
designate rooms within those spaces for
the killing this one's the killing space
this is the killing corner that's the
corner where they cry The Crying Corner
in the killing corner
oh boy all right designated as an
execution room you got it huh yeah
execution whoa man
it just doesn't feel right these new
rooms have requirements before they
become functional yeah
like the kill detonator mm the cell
needs a bed in a toilet the execution
room requires the electric chair oh
we're in that stage of technology we
don't need any lethal injections here
good old-fashioned electricity worked in
the Green Mile it can work here too ok
anyway her babe I probably should rotate
that so it's actually usable and not
faced up against the wall and I want
this to be dead center [ __ ] dead center
so that everyone can gather around in a
big circle and watch him fry oh boy all
righty then
speed it up boink it's eating time
apparently hello friends how's it going
in here Oh were they fighting I couldn't
tell if they were fighting yeah whatever
hi Thomas no not the light hide Paul
Thomas sentenced to five years for
kidnapping he's got a whole family - oh
I can punish him I don't know if I want
to do that yet okay that's the
essentials taken care of but there's
still a few improvements you could make
it's up to you though these aren't
strictly required it depends on how much
you care about your prisoners and their
environment you know their well-being
right before they get blasted through
the brain with 10,000 amps or however I
don't know kill dead okay
the cell itself could be improved with
an outward facing window and a small
bookshelf whoa the execution room could
be improved with live streams for the
whole world to enjoy and the facility
would look better with a higher quality
floor material like wooden floorboards
or mosaic tiles uh-huh
outside you could add some lighting and
a paved pathway if you think it needs it
oh it's mother world is literally my
oyster I get to
make whatever the hell I want to make it
sounds delightful okay and who is always
this is this a guy whoo hello aah whoo
we're doing the slow zoom to raise the
heightening dramatis ism of this one
moment this is the man in question
Edward Romsey well I hope it's not in
question dang it a teacher once would
you believe it's not our place to decide
if he deserves this the law has made
that decision we're just here to do a
job once you're satisfied the facility
is ready you can begin the trician
transfer to his new cell simply click on
the Polaroid in his cell to initiate the
transfer oh okay
ah so before I do that I can add some
niceties to this whoo all right let me
add a paved path because that probably
is necessary is this a right one I hope
so we're gonna get a nice double wide on
this bad boy there that's real pretty
looking we're gonna get some marble tile
in here so that it oh that just made it
look more sinister I don't think it's
quite done but it's there
all right bookshelf you know necessary
oh boy inked a window for the out words
how do we make that out words I wait no
hang on an outwards facing window okay
that's good oh that is a delightful
flooring Oh so tasteful one one one
perfect for the electric chair all right
so that's paving is in progress I guess
that's all the path so lights need to go
winkeny boink and then boink
and then Boing Kitty boink that'll look
real good I imagine wait those do those
go ok did go okay it's good okay so they
got him definitely that looks lovely now
everyone's gonna be happy except for the
guy
dude I okay I added a bookshelf in a
window is that happening
I hope so I think it's happening I think
it happened I'm not a hundred percent
sure hope that window got there yeah the
window got there okay and then the
bookshelf hurry up man you're last in
line I don't care if you have to haul
around an entire bookshelf by yourself
you stop complaining and do your job
really you'll find your guilt no more
all right and way so that is done I got
all of that thankfully I'm do advance
who the chief I don't like the look at
the chief the chief gives me the
heebie-jeebies
reminds me exactly of the chief from
Shawshank Redemption oh boy hmm oh man
oh I need you oh I don't know it's just
so gritty with the Polaroid and the
mustache and his cheekbones are to die
for
literally don't shed one tear for this
guy he's a stone-cold killer killer
guilty as charged
he even confessed want to hear his
description of what he did no I'm fine I
didn't think I would be inundated with
this many more Ballabh legations it's
juicy stuff oh god stop talking it was
around 11:00 p.m. the lights were
already on I knew she was home uh I
don't wanna know oh god oh no no this is
gonna be part of it I thought it was
just gonna be a simulator game whoa
oh okay what the hell oh my god oh good
golly I knew I'd catch you two here Wow
Edwards wife Susan oh yeah okay
Edward don't just doll I don't want to
read this
oh I don't read this Oh God oh whoa
clear as day if you ask me deserves
every volt he's gonna get Wow here I
thought it was gonna be a happy fun game
Wow all men deserve forgiveness even him
are you so sure in yourself that you can
deal out such final judgment catching
your wife with another man is no excuse
for what he did and he went there with a
loaded gun knowing he'd find them
together that's double premeditated
murder he's done nothing but cooperate
with the authorities this state is
making an example out of him if he'd
committed his crime a hundred miles
north he'd be looking at life in prison
instead how is that justice do you want
a guy like this running free I'll sleep
just fine a night when he's the one I
know he's gone oh my goodness this game
is so much heavier oh then I ever
thought it was like this I no idea good
work so far yeah I feel good oh my god
I was games are supposed to be fun and
happy not really but you know thought
this one was gonna be however there is
one problem the execution room isn't I
thought that was gonna say isn't fun yet
because it doesn't have any power we
need to connect it to the electrical
supply okay wow that looks fancy and
interesting how do I do this we are now
viewing the prison in utilities mode
shows us the electrical wiring
lay out for the entire prison oh my god
what did you do to my eyes how can I say
this each building in the prison is
connected to the power grid by these
thick underground electrical cables ah
can these be sabotage power is provided
to the prison by the substation which
draws electricity from the National Grid
okay yeah so prisoners could probably
break that down and then cause all of
the things to open as you can see this
entire wing of the prison cells is
without power all the lights are out to
fix this problem we first need to switch
into utilities mood to understand why
the lights are without power well it's
because the big wire no connect to over
there I've solved it with my big brain
the nearest electrical cables are too
far away our engineers can't complete
the wiring for this area extend the
electrical cables nearby to cover this
wing in the prison okay
utilities mode electrical cable oops
look what look I did it I did it good
still I get it
do I need to do the individual ones or
is this gonna happen I think it's gonna
happen normally right oh aiiah that
doesn't look good I need to be rotated
nah that's fine they'll they'll fix it
yeah they'll fix it I thought they would
yeah go my little minions go look at
them they work so well button and then
i'm guessing i need to connect this over
to here ah debating about a boom okay oh
geez okay lights aren't the only thing
that needs power your new electric chair
does too huh I never would have thought
I was gonna try to put two and two
together but my brain can't handle those
numbers with what I just experienced use
the power cables to connect the
execution facility to the power grid
okay I did that the electric chair
itself is a special type of electrical
item it requires its own dedicated power
line you'll need to connect it up
directly with the main cables I wonder
why it's amperage is so high okay rady
then I think I did it already
oh man these guys work tirelessly boy do
I what are these guys doing out here
are you lost go home geez you don't want
to be here for this alright we're almost
done I think we should test the new
execution room at least once before we
try to use it oh no ohh next thing I
know it's gonna find a small animal to
test it on my god don't do any of this
I'm just gonna turn it on for a few
seconds make sure everything is okay and
make sure nothing's in there
don't even bother looking jeez huh whoa
ah that's not good
well [ __ ] well that didn't work looks
like we drew too much power and tripped
a circuit breaker in the power station
the whole prison is dark we're gonna
need more juice to be able to handle the
power spike that the electric chair
generates okay alright first we need to
turn the power back on this is a
two-step process switch the power
station back on by clicking on it and
selecting the switch on in the menu that
appears then build three more capacitors
so we have enough power capacity to
handle the electric chair once you've
done that test the electric chair again
by clicking on it and Swit selecting
switch on in the main menu you got it I
thought follow dismantle switch on there
we go boom okay so we need more
capacitors of course eCourse yay
that should be enough once doors are
built it's gonna be good seriously why
did they just wander around in that area
over there and then wander around
outside what couldn't you guys who is
sticking around in here actually do
something and help out over there good
golly Miss Molly you guys are not
helpful at all okay uh don't but um but
um okay so now I should be able to test
it out pop him
hubbub okay well done I don't feel like
I did a job well done I believe we are
finished with this job what happens now
is out of our hands we did a
professional job and that's important in
our business yes it's his business just
business
try not to worry about what happens next
oh of course I'm worried of course I'm
worried oh man Oh
yeah
can I help you dot-dot-dot are you
looking for forgiveness I don't know I
have to do something I can't live with
the things I've done you have to turn
yourself in whatever you've done you
cannot evade the consequences you will
never be able to live with yourself
until you face up to your past I want to
go back I want to forgive her I want her
to forgive me God will forgive you no
matter what you've done if you ask him
to
but you must answer for your crimes in
the eyes of the law there is no other
way okay this is so slowly it is time
Edward you have done the right thing
even though this world will not forgive
you for it you will be with God soon and
he will have the final judgment on you
Oh so heavy oh oh man see on the surface
what threw me off is this game looks so
simplistic and I assumed that it would
be more happy fun just a gamy game I had
no idea that it actually had like a
store whoa whoa also I imagine that this
is in another time period probably in
the 50s or 60s or something like that
cuz oh oh man oh man
oh yeah the hood
yeah the hoods a nice touch oh he looks
old Oh Edward Romsey you've been found
guilty of two counts of murder in the
first degree the penalty is death do you
have anything to say Susan oh I'm sorry
chapter 2 oh my goodness
see I came into this oh okay what the
hell is that oh that's not good I know
if you all there's a crisis brewing at
one of our other facilities yeah no
kidding
someone started a fire in the prison
kitchen my priority is to put it out
stop any casualties and prevent more
damage use the emergency services button
in the toolbar to call the fire brigade
get this fire under control before it
burns the whole prison down okay we're
here there ma'am
fire it up how do I do this
what do I do I am so confounded it's
spreading oh do I call them I've gone
both we're calling both of them bringing
the whole squad oh geez oh geez
you might want to hurry the Frick up
what are you doing what are you doing
get over here get in there oh geez oh
gosh oh god that looks bad oh okay how's
that looks bad
Oh God how do i how do i extinguished oh
do i oh oh do I have to like what oh oh
here there I don't know what do you want
right
click the right mouse oh I didn't know
that I find it known I would have done
it no jeez oh god I didn't know I didn't
know we didn't know oh lordy Lou Oh God
you're trying to get out oh that must be
a bad situation to try to control the
prisoners oh man when they're all
scrambling to get out oh wow
spray it spray hard all three deaths who
died who died was there anybody in there
I didn't know there was anybody in there
oh oh oh
oh I didn't mean it Oh No
holy crap
Oh rescue him rescue him rescue him he's
still alive in there Wow
they legitimately like risk their lives
whoa that is nuts that is nuts
IIIi didn't even know that I was like oh
man I care so much about these little
dots don't walk in the fire oh don't
stand right in the fire he's standing
right in the fire oh you're still okay
oh you're still okay ah oh he just went
unconscious okay that's not good oh I
had no idea okay so now that the fire
has been put out I think for the most
part there's still a little ember over
there let me go get that don't don't
stand in the fire just put it out thank
you okay now that that's done now that
the crisis has solved my god there's a
survivor in the wreckage Oh is he the
one that started the fire I have no idea
Christ on a crutch it's dawn Palermo of
all the inmates it just had to be our
mob boss okay the bad news for him is
that the budget cuts have meant we had
to sack all our permanent doctors the
good news is our infirmary is still
usable hire a couple of doctors and
they'll take care of Don Palermo whilst
we sort this mess out oh wow we need to
clear up this mess use the bulldoze tool
to demolish the ruined canteen in
kitchen you need to remove all the
debris okay
designate a garbage zone adjacent to the
road our workmen will dump the wreckage
therefore the garbage trucks to dispose
of finally can you send those firemen
home now that they've done their job and
a few of them died I've added more
details on each of these objectives in
your to-do list any time you're unsure
what to do highlight the objective and
you'll see additional instructions okay
Wow oh man
okay I'm gonna end this episode here
just because I need to wrap my head
around what the hell just happened but
Wow
this game is way way way way more
involved than I thought it was that is
nuts but that prison architect thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm gonna
play some more of this game I want to
know more I came into this thinking I
just got done playing blueprint Tycoon
and I thought it was gonna be kind of
like that I had no idea so this is going
to be a wild experience for me I am very
eager to see what does this tucked-away
why is there a fireman's thing is that a
fireman thing I have no idea - something
took the way over there but either way
he's gonna be a wild ride so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
that was a good option oh it's a good
option okay Oh down here oh good let me
just sort through this with so much care
[ __ ] this guy